The following content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
SAL: Hi.
I'm Sal.
Today we're going to be solving
problem one of exam
three of fall 2009.
Now before you attempt the
problem, there's a couple of
things that you should know or
have background knowledge of
these materials before
starting.
First thing is understanding
the properties of crystal
defects and for this problem
particularly, Frenkel defects,
which we'll talk about.
The formula, which is an
Arrhenius relationship, as a
function of temperature and
energy enthalpy of the
fraction of vacancies that are
formed in a crystal and the
conversion again between
one electron
volt and to the joule.
This will help you solve
the problem.
So the problem reads
as follows.
Silver bromide, which
is AgBr, has rock
salt crystal structure.
So it's an FCC Bravais lattice
with the ion pair Ag plus and
the Br as the basis--
Br minus the basis.
The dominant defect in AgBr
or silver bromide
is the Frenkel disorder.
So it's telling you what the
dominant defective is.
So the question asks, for part
A, so I'll put A here.
Part A for the question asks,
does the Frenkel disorder in
silver bromide create vacancies
of silver plus,
vacancies or Br minus or both?
Explain.
Dionic radii are 0.67 Angstroms
for silver plus and
1.96 Angstroms for
bromine minus.
So that's data that's
given to us.
I'm going to go ahead
and write that down.
So I know from reading about
point defects and crystals
that a Frenkel defect is pretty
much formed when you
have an ion pair of
dissimilar sizes.
So if one of the radii--
like, say, your anion is a lot
bigger than the radius of your
cation, then one should expect
that you would have a Frenkel
defect to form.
And what a Frankel defect is--
which you should know from
reading the material--
is that it's when one of the
ions in your crystal leaves
and leaves back a vacancy--
so just migrates--
just hops out of its lattice
site and leaves back empty
spaces, which is called
a vacancy.
So we're given two things.
If I draw a little picture--
I can call this my silver and
I'll call this my bromine.
And I'm given the fact that the
radius of Ag plus is equal
to 0.67 Angstroms--
and an Angstrom is just 10
to the minus 10 meters--
very small number.
And I'm also given the radius of
bromine, the anion, is 1.96
Angstroms. Now I would argue
that these two have very
dissimilar radii.
Obviously, the bromine looks to
be about three times bigger
than your silver.
So by understanding the
definition of a Frenkel
defect, I can claim that I would
expect the smaller ion
of the two to be the one that
leaves the vacancy behind,
hence forms the Frenkel
defect.
So for part A, do I expect
it to create silver plus
vacancies or Br minus
vacancies or both?
I would expect just to be silver
plus, given the size of
your cation.
So if you were to write on this
problem, just expect only
Ag plus, which is your silver
cation, or the smaller one.
Expect Ag plus smaller ion to
create a vacancy and hence,
this leads to the
Frenkel defect.
So yes, I should expect it
to form a defect now.
If I was given a cation that had
a similar radius that I--
I wouldn't know if I could argue
the fact that this will
form a Frenkel defect or not
because the conditions are
that you have to have the
similar radius between your
cation and your atom--
and it makes sense because
the fact that
your silver is small--
it has more freedom
to hop around.
So it requires less energy for
this smaller atom to then
start hopping around your
lattice site without penalty
or without major penalty
compared to your bromine ion.
So therefore, this is the
one that should be
expected to form that.
OK.
So that's part A.
And part B reads--
calculate the temperature at
which the fraction of Frenkel
defects in a crystal with silver
bromide exceeds one
part per billion.
The enthalpy of Frankel defects
and formation, delta h
sub f, has a value of 1.16
electron volts per defect.
And the entropic pre-factor
A has a value of 3.091.
So it's giving you data.
Now the way I would solve this
problem is that the first
thing I would do is that
I would write down
what my data is.
So I'll call this data and the
first thing is that our
fraction of vacancies that are
formed in silver bromide is
one part per billion--
so 10 to the -9.
That's a fraction so no units.
The second thing that we're
given in the problem is that
our energy of formation--
our enthalpy energy--
is 1.16 electron volts
per defect.
This is the energy penalty for
every time one of your silver
cations jumps out of sight
to create that.
Nothing is free.
Everything requires energy.
We're also given the fact
that A, the entropic
pre-factor, is 3.091--
with no units--
and given our equation
that I showed you
on the bullet point.
That you should know--
you can go ahead and
see what's missing.
So if I write down
my equation--
this is all--
I'll box this off as my data
because I'm going to refer to
this to solve the problem.
And the problem talks
about temperature.
So I know that f sub v is
going to equal to the
pre-factor times the exponent
of negative delta h, of
formation over kb t.
Now you notice that kb wasn't
given to you and kb is both in
its constant.
Now a lot of student forget
that they have a table of
contents in front of them and
that value is in there.
So if you don't know it by
heart, then you want to make
sure that you reference to that
table because a lot of
information will be given to
you, because you're expected
to look at the table
of contents or
your periodic table.
But if I include this
as my data--
I'm going to go ahead and
write it over here--
that kb--
half the value of 1.38 times
10 to the -23 and this has
units of joules for
degree Kelvin.
So this is something that you
should pay particular
attention to because now kb is
in joules for Kelvin, but our
energy was given in
electron volts.
Now this is the number
one thing that
will take off points.
You'll get points taken off if
you don't notice this-- that
you need to go ahead and do the
conversion from electron
volts to joules or joules
to electron volts.
Either which way, you're going
to get the answer.
But the problem asks, calculate
the temperature.
The very first sentence.
So what does that mean?
Well, I'm going to go ahead and
look at my equation and
I'm going to look at the data
that I have and the constants
and see if I'm missing
anything else because
obviously you can't solve an
equation that has two unknowns
and just one equation.
Solve the equation, you've got
to only have one unknown for
the equation.
So f sub v--
no.
Check--
That's given.
Is A given?
It's right here.
That's given as well.
What about delta A sub F?
Well, that's the energy--
the energy penalty to create a
defect and kb, which we got
from our table of
contents, and t.
So this concludes that the only
thing we're not given is
temperature because that's what
we're asked to solve.
So I need to do some math on
here to go ahead and solve for
temperature.
And the first thing I want to do
is take the natural log of
both sides.
So by taking the natural
log of both sides--
so natural log of f sub v--
this equals to natural log of A
plus the natural log of the
exponent part and we know from
math that the natural log of
an exponent cancels each other
out because they're inverses.
So the natural log of exponent,
of negative delta h
sub f, over kb t--
this cancels that and we just
get the natural log of A plus
negative because you have
a negative up here--
delta h of formation
divided by kb t.
So the only thing we don't
know here is temperature.
So if I can rearrange this
equation and solve for
temperature, I can
get an answer.
So if I do that--
what's the best way
of doing that?
Well.
I can add--
I can move this to the other
side and move this to the
other side and that gives me
delta h sub f divided by kb t
equals natural log of A minus
natural log of your vacancy
fraction and I can then multiply
both sides by t so it
cancels this one and it arrives
over here and then
divide both sides
by ln of this.
So I'll go ahead and do that.
So I'll multiply this by t.
Multiply that by t.
So that cancel that and I end up
having delta hf over kb t--
the t got canceled--
this equals to the natural log
of A minus the natural log of
your vacancy fraction times t.
So now if I divide both sides
by this factor, I solve for
temperature.
So this gives me an isolation
that t ends up being delta hf
over kb times the natural log of
A minus the natural log of
the vacancy fraction.
Now all we have to do is plug in
the numbers, but again, if
you look at the units of
Boltzmann's constant, which
are joules per Kelvin and the
value that we're given up here
is electron volts for defect,
we want to go ahead and
convert the electron volt to the
joule because it'll just
be easier to do the
math that way.
So I can go ahead and write
it out and I do that by
multiplying the top by that
conversion factor and if I do
the math, t ends up being--
we have 1.16 of this--
has units of electron volts for
defect and then I want to
get joules because that's what
Boltzmann's constant has.
So in order to get joules,
if I multiply this by the
conversion factor which is
1.6 times 10 to the -19--
this has units of joules
per electron volt.
Now the electron volts
cancel and I get--
the numerator has units
of joules per defect.
That's good because that's going
to cancel with the units
in Boltzmann's constant.
And then I put in 1.38
times 10 to the -23--
this is joules per Kelvin--
and this factor is multiplied
by the natural log of 3.091
minus the natural log
of 10 to the -9.
So unitless--
so if you do the math out, you
end up getting a value that at
the end of the day,
your temperature--
this t right here--
will be equal to--
let's go ahead and write
it over here.
So now that we go ahead
and do the math--
that way it's nice and clean.
We know that the t, the
temperature that we got from
plugging all that math--
ends up being just 615 Kelvin.
And where did the Kelvin
come from?
Well, it came from your joules
per Kelvin, from your
Boltzmann's constant, because
that's what the dimensional
analysis does.
So this is the answer.
This is good.
The problem doesn't say show the
answer in degrees Celsius,
but since everybody knows
degrees Celsius--
everybody in science relies
on degrees Celsius--
you can just convert this over
to degrees Celsius, which
happens to be 342
degrees Celsius.
So this right here is your
answer to part B.
And again, I want to express
again that the crucial part in
getting this is knowing the
fact that you're given an
energy in electron volts, but
the constant that you use has
units of joules.
So you need to convert to get
the right unit out or else you
will get not Kelvin--
you would get something
different here, which wouldn't
make any sense given the
question that was asked.
So with that, again I advise
that-- always read
the problem in detail.
Look at the units that you're
working with and make the
appropriate conversions because
everything should be
on your table of contents.